[Musique]
il ya quelques temps elle était la reine
de la déco sur l'a6 mais aujourd'hui
valérie damidot a disparu de notre petit
écran pour se consacrer à sa chaîne
youtube passé un très bon moment
c'est parti pourtant l'animatrice n'a
pas caché son souhait de revenir à la
télévision au micro d'europe 1 zemmour
et les refaire de la télé une émission
de déco à la télé à graver j'adorerais
mais je crois que la télé mais n'a pas
du tout oui tiens mais lors d'une autre
interview accordée à télé 7 jours
valérie damidot a fait un constat
frappant
je suis passé du côté obscur de la force
la femme de plus de 50 ans en télé c'est
déjà un miracle d'avoir tenu si
longtemps
wealthy le nombre de femmes à la tête
des missions est déjà trop faible passé
la cinquantaine leur place sur est
quasiment inexistante
même en 2021 et bien que les chaînes
s'en défendent il faut que les
animatrices soit mince jeune et un peu
lisse une remarque avait déjà fait
christine bravo il ya quelques mois et
qui témoigne du profond problème de
parité à la télévision alors est ce que
c'est on trouve qu'il manque de femmes
de plus de 50 ans étaient des enfants
comment il va effet voté pour cartes à 8
août a alors totalement je trouve
qu'elle a totalement raison
on a l'impression que les rides signe la
retraite dans ce milieu donc je trouve
ça vraiment injuste après c'est vrai
qu'il faut avoir du talent pour
continuer sa certes je suis d'accord
mais pour le koala elle a vraiment
raison vraiment alors bis mais je suis
très riche mais en fait ce sont les
femmes qui manque à la télé pas plus de
50 moins de cinq ans il manque des
femmes il y à des programmes de niches
qui évidemment sont toujours dédiés aux
hommes
on s'est un petit peu comment ça se
passe maintenant je pense que valérie
damidot elle prêche pour sa paroisse
elle a envie de revenir on peut le
concevoir
je crois que son départ de m6 et s avec
un petit peu chaotique à l'époque elle a
voulu cesser autre chose sauf qu'elle
est douée en déco et c'est pas une
animatrice à la base c'est vrai que ça
même si c'est un et duarte n'est pas de
putsch canada prendront tellement
récupérer la production ont vidangé
d'aider leur seule la wii c'est avec de
plus un peu court un peu plus compliqué
si vous ne vous êtes non mais c'est que
kembo jusqu'à la fin créateur d'émotions
il ya un truc question après c'est
qu'elle ne regarde pas parce que les
plus de 50 ans on a quand même
emilie lopez ces rachats brouillé avec
nous je n'ai caire
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve que le quota est là mais
déjà que c'est pas dangereux voilà de
faire une remarque sur l'âge
oui 49 48 50 52 et pourquoi on a jugé
nettement faire là je suis allé se bat
déjà des femmes de plus de 50 ans elle
est à la télé il y en a claire chazal
sur france 5
laurence ferrari sur ses news
anne-sophie latif souffrant des dents a
ajouté laurence boccolini on pourrait
tuer à l'elysée oui oh bah oui car la
mer est le marchand gecina cordula l on
la verrait les anime
bien sûr que c'est pas ça le vrai
problème ce problème et sans fonds c'est
le cas elles se trompent de combat c'est
panache c'est le style de l'animation
réanimateur et les ammonites doivent se
renouveler
est-ce qu'elle renouvelait il son style
je suis pas totalement manqué de dire
n'est pas mannequin elle n'est pas bonne
a dit ça que ça regarde il faut parfois
se renouveler dans son film d'animation
la preuve près de vous a donné une liste
de ses animatrices de plus 50 ans qui
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait des métaux
claire chazal que j'adore sur france 5
avait du coeur chazal oui mais là
paronnaud elle a pas révolutionner le
journalisme sur france 5 lui
correspondait et aujourd'hui il faut
aller sur des cas ce qui correspond au
profil du jeu pardon non c'est une façon
la mairie en fait ce que je voulais dire
c'est que c'est tout maintenant à la
télé en tout cas ces bases est vachement
sur le physique donc à partir du moment
où une femme commence à vieillir c'est
où elle fait de la chirurgie et c'est
pour ça qu'on a beaucoup d'ailleurs dans
ce milieu on a tendance à nous rabaisser
île qui fait notre jury dans ce but 2
pendant tout le monde à part moi
après je me présente quand on porte une
robe la voterons non sur des choix
intéressant c'est la phrase dans son
entier elle dit il faut que les
animatrices soit mince jeune et un peu
lisse et c'est vrai que là en ce moment
valérie elle travaille chez tf1 comme
regarder les animatrices de tf1 c'est un
petit peu ça sert qu'elle a aujourd'hui
sur tf1 ya ellis mito narnia karine
ferri et alessandra sublet qu'à mon sens
pas assez de programmes scolaires enfin
par rapport à la carrière qu'elle
devrait avoir et je suis assez d'accord
avec elle par mois tf1
la place des femmes géré au top on prête
à aller pas gigantesque injuste je suis
autant de largesses télévision par
contre on fait beaucoup de place aux
femmes et je trouve ça assez louable
donc en fait ça dépend vraiment des
groupes sur tf1 ça ne va pas et sur
france télévisions je trouve que c'est
mieux qu'il ya vraiment deux faits pour
un peu plus de diversité oui le bas ne
coûtait j'ai déjà parlé mais vous voulez
que je vois pas non
j'ai confondu le et kevin na d'areva
c'est christopher j'ai un triptyque là
je n'étais pas là
ludivine ristori t bills qui ça ne se
ressemblent pas
alors j'ai fait un prénom kevin pardon
c'est ça on est vendredi vendredi c'est
d'ailleurs de la semaine ça va bien non
la part de valérie damidot je trouve ça
un petit peu facile parce qu'il faut
bien le rappeler que depuis qu'elle est
partie d'annecy ce qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait qu' à fonctionner la télé nrj 12
c'est un bide total
là bas j'ai d'énormes troncs superbe et
dakhla des rayons ça c'est vous qui
allez faire ce genre de critique est
clair il faut quand même rappeler sur
tf1 à vie secrète des chats mon plus
beau noël et plus mes vacances elle
était sur un siège a commenté sur des
voitures des trucs était qui est
invraisemblable et je sais que valérie
damidot il ya quelques temps avait
tourné un pilote pour une chaîne de
télévision est une productrice elle
était très difficilement gérable sur le
plateau il ya aussi cette cep cette
notion de producteurs qui ont aussi
parfois du mal à travailler que certains
animateurs qui sont difficilement
gérable sur des émissions et d'aller
raid et meadow aujourd'hui on fait
partie en concédant milieu donc à m'en
faut aussi se remettre en question il ya
aussi les audiences il ya la chasse doit
être humainement ya pa pe c'est vrai que
globalement parfois il ya des animateurs
qui dépannait d'or à la base qui vous
veut le sortir de ce qui ce problème
était connu et c'est parfois ce fait une
erreur divise et qui veut gagner des
millions de là-bas chez starling et
c'est à râler à l'antenne du jour au
lendemain
voilà donc après il ya eu aussi des
carrières qui s'offrent à elle en
télévision pourquoi pas l'abolition
mêlant l'animateur franchement ça métier
attendez moi